il y a une semaine delphine wespiser
s'est exprimé au sujet de la
présidentielle expliquant sa déception
concernant le mandat d' emmanuel macron
en 2010 a déjà voté manuel mata kron je
suis très très déçu et déclarant vouloir
opter pour le changement lors de cette
élection au deuxième tour il ya une
personne où il ya une autre on a déjà
laissé une personne ça ne me correspond
pas prise de position en faveur de
marine le pen qui a poussé l'art comme
ainsi que la chaîne a de voir des
comptes et son temps de parole qui
delphine a reçu beaucoup de menaces pour
avoir exprimé son opinion j'ai eu des
milliers d' insulte mais millier de
menaces rassurez vous c'est personnage
de blanche et deux rouges quelqu'un dans
fort boyard ne seront pas impactés la
production du jeu a annoncé que delphine
wespiser ferait bien partie de la
prochaine saison peu importe ses choix
politiques alors après ses prises de
position dans tpm paix delphine wespiser
ne sera pas écarté de fort boyard
comprenez vous cette décision
elles bonnes décisions non mais c'est
vrai ça aurait six mecs y un oui donc
que ça choque les gens à titre personnel
moi je peux peut-être le comprendre en
revanche à titre professionnel n'y a pas
de raison et je ne comprends même pas
que la production ait fait un communiqué
ils n'ont pas justifier là-dessus quand
une personnalité prend position pour
emmanuel macron elle n'est jamais menacé
de se faire évincer ont remplacé d'une
émission donc pourquoi le faire là c'est
pas parce qu'elle a pris position c'est
qu'elle a pris position pour marine le
pen et je trouve ça un peu injuste n'est
ce pas cyril oui bien sûr c'est injuste
non mais ça aurait été injustement et
s'intéresserait à ce que des ouï la
suite eu plus j'ai pas aimé cette
question où il avait changé sur l'accord
avec guillaume mais sur le fait que la
production face un communiqué vous avez
tort c'est très bien parce que ça m'a
pas la chose je suis désolé dans
certains médias brut à cliquer y avait
beaucoup de questionnements il
commençait à dire fort et les cartes et
la production la firme c'est un gage de
continuité c'est une très bonne décision
c'est vrai ça malsain parce que
justement ça cela corrobore le fait que
quand on dit qu'on veut on nous dira que
votre marine le pen ont peu de laque
liste et je trouve que c'est envoyer un
très mauvais message donc je trouve
qu'ils ont eu tort et la soutenir
message que ses employeurs la soutienne
c'est très sain non je suis pas sûr est
ce que c'était vraiment une façon de la
soutenir où ils se sont vraiment posé la
question de liberté et parfois raison
mais peu importe que la production
l'employeur la firme je collectionne les
rumeurs parce qu'elle est derrière oui
sur moi terminé hier
s'en serait ça a été ça a été fait
vraiment
dans les règles de l'art et bien sûr il
a été fait ce qu'il fallait faire
un programme pour les enfants
effectivement je pense que que pas que
les enfants moi j'adore mais pas
principalement évoquée voter marine le
pen est vantée marine le pen dans les
enfants jeux parce que c'est un très
bonne idée après j'aurai
un rôle de composition elle est connue
qu'après une personne très influente est
intervenue et elle a récupéré son poste
quelle chance est là
la sélection au sein de france 2 s'est
pas posée honnêtement que quitte à quai
sur s'est pas posée au sein de france 2
s'est
vautré rallonge arrêtez vous mentez là
encore c'est pas mon équipe
s est posé mais l activité est écarté et
comme a dit batteries sont pas
dramatiques la première est qu une
personne publique ce besoin non mais
elle à l attention m l'a dit mais là
attention ne lui fait pas dire au final
je sais la dca contre ma croix
elle a dit on a déjà essayé la dernière
fois macro maintenant ils s'appellent
passe à autre chose il ya deux candidats
ces femmes accros c'est marine le pen
feux
d'artifice avaient été mélangées
l'apathie qu'elle allait voter mais on
va pas vers le titre natixis avait pas
été marine le pen la nature et la
distance afin de faire les débats sur
fort boyard quatre pense qu'ils ont eu
là bas c'est ce qu'attend le dur a dit
pas moi j'aurais trouvé ça tellement
injuste tellement soviétique encore une
fois ça veut dire qu'on dit aux gens en
gros si vous votez pour marine le pen
dont vous n'avez plus droit de bosser
donc ça me sert pas mettre division qui
dit ben moi je vote pour marine le pen
vous avez plus droit d'être avocat je
peins myriam palombes à elle et à la
rédaction public vous avez marée noire
c'est un programme
fait qu'en droit d'être étiqueté par
rapport à ce que tu penses ça veut dire
que ça veut dire qu'elle est les oubliés
de caché d'être hypocrite sur ce qu'a
dit mathieu à propos de delphes alors
barreau dit nous parce que alors oui
justement matthieu delormeau vous
laissez entendre que la position de
delphine wespiser qui n'est pas un
soutien explicite à marine le pen mais
qui est plutôt anti macro poser problème
du tout ramasser ce que vous avez
répondu une maladie je veux que ce soit
la maman les françaises laisser mijoter
écoutez moi si j'ai accepté la
production leur génie et vous aviez
l'air de le regretter en donc fort
boyard est une émission pour enfants je
trouve votre position scandaleuse parce
que c'est rétablir la censure ou établir
la santé
si on doit aller dans un sens celui qui
est le vôtre en l'occurrence parce que
vous n'avez pas beaucoup de cas
passionnant travail
mais clément guérin n'a marché
totalement d'accord avec le fait que
delphine reste à fort boyard j'ai
beaucoup d'à priori avec elle il ya
aucun problème mais bon ce que je
voulais dire c'est qu'il ya deux âmes
qui revient challans ans devait faire
fort boyard et ils ne l'ont pas mis par
rapport à ça il y avait quand même des
photos avec l'extrême droite ils ne
l'ont pas admis non je pense que la
question s'est posée quand même bizarre
est là qu est ce que ces 15 ne peut pas
écarter quelqu'un de son poste un an des
raisons politiques déjà c'est un délit
d'opinion c'est illégal et serait
demandé à mathieu si donc il serait en
faveur qu'elle perde son job et donc les
revenus qui vont arriver au calcul des
faits s'ils n'ont pas cessé ses formes
tpm pc pas l'air de rien font fort
boyard si on est surveillé alors avec
les jolis valeur mais bon les enfants
demuru marine et bien voyons dans le
monde politique a
démâté pmp on parle de certaines choses
assez des questions à narbonne s'éduquer
sa forme actuelle et déguisés en gardes
la dame blanche poilus avoir
peur il
apprend que sa mère qu'elle perde son
jab écouter alors et du père il ya eu
deux filles qui sont pas finies mais
c'est comme ça qu'elle a récupéré donc
mes parents auraient dû perdre son job a
bien que jamais la vie sauve d'un
scandale oui
extrêmement bas tu vraiment trembler
dégrafer pas demander aux gens en
assurant imagine tête à 32 % dans les
intentions de vote au premier tour
c'était 32% des français qui ont voté
pour des examens je repose la question
alors été élus au premier tour elle
serait restée en
démocratie
ce sont des candidats qui ont eu leurs
500 signatures qui se présentent
débats c'est pas des grands politique
royale un million de forcément c'est
très bien que ça donne l'impression même
d entreprise lambda oui elles sont
prisées de ces grands de mètres carrés
des gens pour j'ai grandi en politique
c'est extrêmement grave et ceux qui
donnent des leçons de démocratie à tout
le monde a joué 24 en donnant les leçons
de morale on ne peut pas et que vous
puissiez dire ça franchement c'est
extrêmement choquée c'est ce qui devrait
nourrir les gens c'est leur tenue
vestimentaire qu'elle ne va pas avec la
société donc c'est comme ça quand même
assez simple c'est ce que j'ai fait
guillaume genton
programme honteux mais ailleurs
vous étiez d'accord avec macron sur le
fait d'enlever l'anonymat de plus de
pseudo mais vous comprenez que justement
ça sert à ça vous disiez on n'est pas en
dictature on peut dire ce qu'on veut
donc on n'a pas besoin d'anonymat sauf
que dans votre logique on ne peut pas
dire ce qu'on veut donc on a besoin de
sous pas comme d anonymat pour pouvoir
maintenant et donner des hôpitaux dit la
dame blanche et que les ai vus jaune
d'amis pur totalement
non
il étudie cyril
l'album a été viré un mathieu oui mais
pas que vous ne verrez rien à voir
maintenant c'est de dire que c'est une
émission pour les enfants je vois pas en
quoi c'est un argument à quel moment les
enfants on ne doit absolument pas leur
parler du front national
fort boyard ce n'est pas une émission tu
parle de faits politiques c'est une
émission de divertissement et les
enfants eh ben il quand on leur parle de
politique eh ben on va pas non le vrai
l'extrême droite n'existe par écouter
c'est en disant que ça allait maintenant
vous avez quelques je venais de garoua
aussi
[Applaudissements]
delphine wespiser à turenne à démonter
d'envoyer est soupçonné il est fou c'est
compliqué pour
2011 est complètement battu non mais
honnêtement le combat médiatique de la
française heureusement pour nous gérons
des coûts de matière à dire gilles
autant de conviction qu'un drapeau dans
le ventoux change tout tu sais pas ce
que tu dis
tu peux pas dire que 32% des gens sont
un pur avec les fous mais web a raison
car ses joies je dirais que je trouve
qu'il a raison je
dis ça je dis que c'est un programme
pour les enfants les enfants
des idées
à nicolas de tolérance
tout à fait ça non mais d'arrêt
enfin pas de fracture oui c'est clair ça
veut dire que toutes les personnes qui
votent marine le pen est parrain d'un
des magasins pour jouer par une âme qui
vous dénude
[Applaudissements]
ils ont préféré il est devant tout le
monde est là le 6 mai même si
dieudonné
s'était bien rendu aux états unis mais
plusieurs haltes routières un procès de
béatrice exactement je trouve ça
scandaleux dieudonné a été condamné pour
des propos antisémites site mois à
propos antisémites et côté delphine
baissé dans ces vaisseaux oui vous
réfléchirez vous dirai
donc c'est un ami donc mathieu on peut
pas exprimer on n'a pas à moi de dire
alors qu'on vote pour raconter deux
quinquennats le mur elle soit là on ne
peut pas le dire
mathieu maintenant que ça veut dire ça
alors oui
déjà et c'est pourquoi ils disent autour
de la table y en a une qui a dit qu'elle
vaut trn c'est un français sur deux qui
votent à rennes où déjà autour de la
table il ya des menteurs ça c'est sûr
menteur là qui me disent j'ai pas envie
de le dire je reste
on est d'accord
les médias ne sont pas représentatifs de
la population hier c'est sur la zone
apac immo terrance et parfois
l'extrême droite c'est là qu'on la met
en valeur surtout moi j'aime venir voir
je pense aussi à tous les électeurs à
duration nationale moi je dis je ne peux
plus je n'en peux plus des gens qui
aiment danser qui les voilà qu'ils les
respectent pas ce
qui m'attire montée en liga il faut
arrêter je le redis encore une fois on
peut pas se mettre à la place des gens
vous vous avez et nous je mets encore
plus moi je le dis la vérité voilà on a
de très belles vies et on ne peut pas se
mettre à la place des gens qui ont d
énormes difficultés oui qui se disent à
un moment on n'en peut plus on
veut que ça change et peut-être que
voilà je le dis n'a pas non plus
beaucoup de difficultés oui mais c'est
sur wii mais
bien sûr losc pour bien quatre gars qui
a beaucoup de difficultés exactement
vous avez raison aucun candidat d'
absolument je vous avez parfaitement
raison sauf que quand c'est un programme
familial en garde
on les veut
les valeurs de l'autre en fait les
valeurs de la tolérance que
jamais avec toi parce que
ces gens qui souffrent et respirer mais
quel rapport avec delphine
finir vous énervez pas quand vous est
réputée comme ça si vous savez vous mais
c'est vrai c'est ce qui a fait rôtir l'a
souvent tire la retenir la
cola qui le souffle ils sont désespérés
sauvetage vous ne pouvez pas comprendre
je ne peux pas le con mais quel rapport
avec la dame blanche et delphine a
exprimé le fait que des gens puissent
voter pour un volant chez les écolos
oui mais c'est le papa avec son médecin
a été commis
[Applaudissements]
crois moi j'aime bien qu une couille des
choix la pétanque
il n'y a qu'une chose soit elle est hors
la loi
elle a une opinion qui est sûr le jour
l'opinion de voter pour marine le pen
fait ça ne va pas l'empêcher de tracé
n'est pas porté aux questions de la
police des frontières
alors quand elle va faire des contrats
parce que ça va lui arriver les contrats
de mode ou je sais pas quoi elle sera
pas hors la loi et pour autant va
enlever du conte dans les landes et
le
dénoncera le dénoncera oui et non ça me
donne envie échoué à réparer moi je
soutiens mathieu arrêter d'y rester
fermes ago et hypocrite et qu'elle vous
et vous les bonnes questions pourquoi sa
chute et laisse ton truc bernadin jeune
femme miss france censée symboliser la
france a osé et ça elle a eu du courage
dira vous ai témoigné de sa sympathie à
marine le pen c'est pour ça qu'à une
polémique et à rythme s'il est une bande
de faux cul parce que vous êtes tous à
la défendre en coulisse serbe a dit donc
quand même et le vote marine le pen etc
vous banalisez celi d'opinion le
l'imposé est donc donné la permission à
tous les autres chefs d'entreprise de
faire la même chose où il ya deux
cerveaux et puis le reste vous confondez
des coûts au confort
mais je dois le dire
le fait d'être critique moi je me suis
positionné pour personne je n'ai voilà
il n'y a pas de problème avec ça
mais ça m'a causerait des problèmes de
dette dans la critique de la ligne
officielle voilà je vous le dis
sincèrement et c'est à dire sur les
vaccins etc mais je n'ai jamais parlé du
vaccin marchés d'actions
c'est une aberration ça vous laisse des
enfants ça vous ôte peu coudouy ça va
causer des problèmes encore ce matin
j'ai reçu un coup de fil alors on vous
dit pas directement que c'est à cause de
ça parce que encore une fois c'est
illégal et savent très bien que c'est
illégal mais il ya des façons de jambes
on vous a refusé des rôles tout ça pour
ça je ne veux pas rentrer dans parce que
je ne veux pas après 15 ans soit à
nouveau utilisé contre lui mais sa cause
des problèmes et c'est extrêmement corsé
ces choses-là honteux alors qu'en plus
je n'ai rien dit de particulier juste je
n'adhère pas à la ligne officielle
jeunes et soutenu personnes en plus
vraiment je ne me reconnais dans aucun
candidat donc vraiment pour le coup je
suis je suis tranquille avec ça et même
six jours me reconnaissaient dans un
candidat comme delphine je vois pas où
serait le problème et ce n'est pas mon
cas je ne soutiens personne et le fait
d'avoir été critique avec la ligne de la
voilà ça m'a causé des problèmes ça
complètement à voir et vous banalisez en
défendant sa vous banalisez ça et donc
pour des gens qui moi je suis pas dans
le besoin financièrement mais tant
qu'ils sont mais je vous dis il ya des
gens qui le sont moi le coup de fil de
ce matin et va pas changer ma vie mais
il ya des gens pour qu'ils se faire
virer ou de se mettre de faire mettre à
l'écart d'un job ça va changer quand ils
me diront plus nourrir leurs enfants ils
pourront
dit
et dire que ce qu'elle a dit ne va pas
avec les valeurs de cette tenait
tout dire sur un tottenham 2-0 grands
one elles peuvent dire où elle veut ça
ne va pas avec les valeurs de cette
émission qui était d'alain bienveillante
familial avec des enfants les sous
daniela mathieu tu es en train mais de
rendre service à marine le pen c'est
sympa 30 secondes a expliqué à dow n'a
rien évidemment sans doute des racistes
mais il ya peut-être des racistes qu'on
votait déjà dit qu'ils étaient à cela
ils sont irrécupérables mais il ya plein
de gens qui votent elle est quand même
arrivée première dans plein plein de
petites communes rurales ils votent
marine le pen parce qu'une chanson je
suis reprise est pas entendue et là tu
es en train de leur dire que quelqu'un
qui aurait comme elles sont pas pieux
qui va distribuer les impurs elle ne
peut plus attention familial mais là
mais marine le pen va t'envoyer un petit
mot de remerciement daniel arrête avec
cette démagogie
l'inversé la démagogie on peut dire d
luffy ya plein de musulmans qui la
regardent un fort boyard et le vote pour
quelqu'un qui veut interdire le voile on
peu l'inversé aussi
c'est bien de quoi c'est que les gens
qui regardent fort boyard ils sont en
train de penser à la politique anti
censure garde et delphine avec sa
perruque ils sont en train de penser à
bâtir la politique tarifaire
plus vous le dis la bac sur bnp
le père pour
nous
on
n'a pas tort pourquoi tu me tillie est
en panne il a dû faire un communiqué
pour dire que c'est un peu compliqué
mais oui mais oui c'est des imbécilités
comme vous qui font rire sylvie tellier
c'est sans nécessité comme vous exprimer
mais vous qui font que sylvie tellier
douanes envie de vendre la parole au nom
de la neutralité montargis mobile je te
rappelle qu'à trois semaines a déclaré
si ça tourne bien mais les électeurs du
front national et les graphismes affinés
au camp des drapeaux dans le vent tu
changes de l'émission
il
l'epadesa a dit ce qu'il a dit oui ils
avaient des saris ce qu'il a dit richard
qui l'avait dit l'avait dit tous les
électeurs du front national sur maciste
dinars pour gêner après jay dee après
d'ailleurs que j'aurais pas dû le dire
devant murata canadien ce qui
s'était passé dit devant mourad
boudjellal voilà qu'elle à jour là où
c'est un semblant d'être malade comme
tous les vendredis
[Applaudissements]